j'ai choisi de pourir c'est ma passion
c'est pas facile tous les jours avec 80
kg de plus que la moyenne j'adapte ma
foulée j'adapte mon cardio mon
souffle mais tu vois ça redescend plus
vite
qu'avant il y a un an et demi je restais
comme ça en boucle en fait là il prépare
une course assez importante pour lui
c'est la première fois qu'il va la faire
il va réaliser une course qu'on appelle
la Sainté lion on va partir sur quelque
chose de réalisable voilà 13 km c'est
une course mythique de nuit et je pense
que tout coureur qui un jour voilà a
fait plus plusieurs courses dans sa vie
a envie d'aller voir a envie d'y être tu
s fier de toi là pas encore on verra
[Musique]
après